[Música]
sin conocernos nos reconocemos nos dice
nicolás guillén
y sin conocernos voy a contarles una
historia de mi infancia cuando yo tenía
5 años
mis papás de navidad me regalaron una
muñeca una muñeca barbie que cumplía con
todos los patrones estéticos de belleza
esta muñeca tenía la piel blanca el
cabello rubio y los ojos claros sin duda
esta muñeca se convirtió en una de mis
favoritas pero a los pocos días un amigo
de mi papá trajo juguetes para mí para
mis hermanos y entre ellos trajo a esta
otra muñeca barbie que tenía rasgos muy
diferentes porque tenía el cabello
castaño los ojos negros y la piel morena
mi papá la tomo y me la entregó muy
seguro de que iba a gustarme igual que
la otra muñeca sin embargo para mí fue
una muñeca y la puse en un rincón sin
darle mucha importancia a los pocos días
había creado mi club de muñecas y
mientras jugaba bajo la cama empecé a
jugar entre estas muñecas con mi papá
y mi papá vio la muñeca y me dijo aquí
estás jugando porque esa muñeca está en
un rincón
entonces yo le dije bueno lo que pasa es
que en este juego esta muñeca es la
empleada y papá se quedó viendo y me
dijo y porque es la empleada porque es
fea y es sucia
y me pregunto por qué es fea y sucia
entonces yo le dije porque es negra
mi papá guardó silencio
y obviamente sin darme cuenta yo lo
había lastimado porque mi papá era un
hombre de chocolate mi papá era un
hombre de chicaloma afroboliviano así
que entenderán cómo fue complicado ese
momento
sin embargo mi papá era una persona muy
inteligente muy noble y las semanas
siguientes él continuó jugando con la
muñeca y él siempre tomaba esta muñeca
la cambiaba de ropa y siempre hacía que
el juego gire en torno a esta muñeca
y sin conocernos
muchos nos reconocemos con esa niña
con el paso del tiempo esta niña creció
y pasó por un proceso de identidad
para este proceso ocurrieron una serie
de eventos que ayudaron a construir uno
de estos eventos fue una fotografía que
fue tomada para una revista que iba a
salir a nivel nacional con un afro
setentero increíble de el que no me
sentía nada orgullosa de hecho no quería
que salga la revista tenía muchos los
comentarios de burla que podrían haber y
sin embargo fue todo lo contrario fue
como el primer paso de aceptarme el
siguiente evento fue una charla con una
antropóloga llamada sheila walker ella
es afrodescendiente norteamericana que
nos presentaba un libro que se llamaba
conocernos desde adentro
este libro hablaba acerca de la cultura
afro latinoamericana entre ella hablaba
de la cultura afro boliviana a mí me
sorprendió porque la verdad nunca había
visto una mujer tan orgullosa entró a la
sala con un porte increíble feliz de
sentirse afrodescendiente entonces
cuando acabó la charla yo me acerque
a preguntarle y a presentarme también
porque ya sabía tanto acerca de la
cultura afro boliviana y yo como
afrodescendiente no de hecho no me
interesaba mucho hasta que en ese
momento ella me dijo una frase que se
quedó dando vueltas en mi cabeza durante
meses y años esta frase fue cuando yo le
dije soy artista me dijo tienes en tus
manos una herramienta muy fuerte con la
que puedes contar tu historia la
historia de tu cultura pero para eso
tienes que empezar a leer empezar a
conocer más acerca de tu cultura para
poder transmitir esto a través de tu
arte
la frase se quedó en mi cabeza por días
y cuando llegue a casa le conté a mi
papá y le dije papi sabías que los afros
han hecho esto sabías que los afros
vienen de tal lugar sabías entonces que
de tan envuelta con el tema en la cabeza
que a la semana siguiente en la
universidad empecé a revisar todos los
libros que te hablarán de lo que era
arte africano
sin embargo encontré
muy pocos libros de hecho sólo dos en
los que hablaba un poco de lo que era el
arte africano y eso me llamó mucho la
atención porque las referencias que
teníamos eran totalmente europeas donde
los protagonistas en definitiva no eran
afros e ir igual se quedó ahí es el
pensamiento
entre esta búsqueda encontré una tesis
en la carrera que hablaba acerca de la
identidad afro y un proyecto que hablaba
de empezar a pintar en las comunidades
el paisaje pero no hablaba de pintar a
las personas que habitan en este paisaje
es decir en el sector de los yungas
esto igual se quedó ahí y empecé a
buscar qué artistas bolivianos teníamos
que pinten como protagonistas a afro
bolivianos no cuál era nuestra situación
en el arte para mi sorpresa encontré que
habían algunos retratos algunas pinturas
que se hicieron pero en ninguna había
este tema de empezar a pintar desde
adentro esa es una cosa muy diferente
alguien que pinta lo que está viendo que
alguien que pinta desde dentro como
afrodescendiente pintando a
afrodescendientes
en todo este proceso de búsqueda empecé
a experimentar
con diferentes técnicas entre
serigrafías grabados dibujos empecé a
hacer un proyecto de fotografía con
pintura en la piel y entre estos
proyectos lo interesante era que había
empezado a construir también algo en
casa hablando con mi papá logré una de
las cosas más importantes en mi vida
hasta ahora que a medida que yo iba
hablando todo el tiempo de la cultura
afro mi papá fue sanando un poco esas
heridas que habían quedado y empezó a
hablar de su comunidad y el deseo que
tenía de volver nuevamente a chicaloma
por cuestiones de salud fue un poco
complicado poder hacerlo y esa tarea
quedó pendiente conmigo
al poco tiempo que mi papá falleció yo
hice mi primera exposición
esta exposición estaba basada en esta
idea de que los protagonistas sean la
imagen afroboliviana y de hecho tome
materiales que para mí significaba mucho
como el metal reciclado que es un metal
encerrado
en el que me permitía poder pintar las
luces de las imágenes a frost entonces
pintaba luces en fondos oscuros y otra
de las cosas que me gustaban era poder
utilizar puertas poder utilizar ventanas
que transmitían un mensaje y también
tenían una historia cada puerta y cada
objeto posteriormente ya empecé a
experimentar con mesas con sillas y cada
mesa y cada silla también contaba una
historia de la persona que era retratada
esta exposición me llevó a recorrer
diferentes ciudades de bolivia pude
hablar acerca de mi arte y de la cultura
afro boliviana en otros países y también
pude dar algunos talleres y charlas y
entre estas charlas encontré también a
mi familia de chicaloma que es algo muy
muy bonito que no esperaba que ocurra
algo que me encanta del trabajo que hago
es poder reflejar un poco lo que es no
solamente la imagen copiada tal cual
sino empezar a copiar y de alguna manera
plasmar lo que son los rasgos que
caracterizan a cada persona y esto es
permitido precisamente por esta analogía
con los materiales y la historia que
conllevan
entre estos retratos
pinte en una ocasión a una de las tías
de chicaloma que se llama martín y
navarra
y me encantó su historia porque era una
mujer muy luchadora con mucha energía y
que siempre decía que uno tiene que
luchar desde donde está y nunca dejes de
estudiar no te des por vencido no
importa cuántos años tengas me gustó
tanto su historia que le hice un retrato
sin decirle y solo la invite a la sala
cuando ya estaba en exposición el
momento que ella vio su retrato que es
justo en esta fotografía
se produjo algo muy intenso porque era
esta combinación entre arte e identidad
y si de repente queda en el aire todavía
esta pregunta de por qué es importante
un arte con identidad desde mi
experiencia como artista puedo decirles
que un arte con identidad lo que hace es
abrir otras puertas es mostrarnos otras
realidades contadas desde sus
protagonistas no es lo mismo una pintura
como en este ejemplo que nos muestra que
ina ericsson que es una curadora
brasileña que hacía referencia a esta
pintura de manet
donde muestra dos realidades una como
protagonista la mujer europea que estaba
en una posición de libertad del cuerpo
de mujer pero detrás de ella tenemos el
cuerpo de la mujer africana en una
situación de opresión entonces este tipo
de lecturas de repente no los vemos a
simple vista hasta que empezamos a de
repente meternos un poco en la pintura y
a ver quién es protagonista en cada
cuadro y cuando uno pinta desde su
identidad
puedes darle la vuelta a esto y mostrar
lo que son los rasgos las actitudes y
todo esto que nos gusta de nuestra
cultura
en este proceso de ir modificando y
cambiando y buscando que podía darle un
plus de repente al trabajo que iba
haciendo realice una investigación para
mi última exposición y llega un momento
de crisis por dos cosas una que había
demasiada información y no sabía cómo
ponerla entonces realicé una línea de
tiempo donde contaba lo que era la
historia afroboliviana lo que genera un
espacio de análisis de diálogo y también
de debate porque yo hablaba justo de
esta etapa de esclavitud y cuál había
sido el paso y el proceso que se ha
tenido que dar para que podamos contar
con nuestra libertad si bien en la
constitución a partir de 1825 se habla
de una libertad la verdad es que recién
en la revolución de 1952 tenemos
y la fin de la opresión o de estos
abusos que se vivían dando en las
haciendas
si nos basamos en estos datos puedo
decir que yo soy la segunda generación
de afrodescendientes nacida libre en
bolivia
y esto conlleva a cuánta historia existe
de estas migraciones que se dan a partir
de este punto migraciones a la ciudad
pérdida de identidad y este deseo
también de blanqueamiento que se va
dando y que continúa en algunos casos
y esto me estos temas son los que me
apasionan porque a partir del arte yo
puedo plantear los y puedo ponerlos como
puntos de debate de hecho el segundo
punto de esta crisis que les cuento era
analizar a partir de que uno se
identifica como afrodescendiente es
decir yo me identifico como afro no por
los rasgos genotípicos sino porque tenía
un abuelo o una abuela o una mamá o mis
papás eran afros pero de repente el
color de piel no dice lo mismo entonces
el empezar a ver este tipo de historias
también es algo bien interesante porque
nos damos cuenta que la construcción de
identidad viene dándose de diferentes
lados
cuando hablamos del tema de identidad
estamos hablando de un proceso bastante
difícil porque tenemos que ver qué tipo
de historias existe detrás de cada
persona
puede que estas historias sean en
algunos casos cargadas de mucho
resentimiento y rechazo y hay muchos
otros de mucho amor y mucho orgullo
cuando hablamos de identidad estamos
hablando
de amor
y de autoestima
el amor que debemos de sentir hacia
nosotros y también hace esa historia de
esas personas que han tenido que dar su
vida en muchos casos y sacrificar muchas
cosas para que nosotros nos hemos de
libertad y de muchos privilegios el
aprender a amarnos y amar al otro parte
de aceptarnos y esto cambia estos estas
ideas que a veces tenemos de valorar a
partir de ciertos estereotipos
que nos impiden conocernos
voy a pedirles que saquen sus celulares
y lo pongan en modos el pin que activen
la cámara
muy bien
tómense un momento para ver a la persona
que aparece en la pantalla
ahora
a quien ven en la pantalla reconocen a
la persona que están viendo aman a la
persona que están viendo
qué es lo que los rasgos de esta persona
cuenta acerca de sus antepasados
el poder vernos al espejo cada día
y aceptar toda esta historia y todo lo
que vemos en este espejo nos ayuda a
construir
y generar cambios dejar de etiquetar
dejar de valorar a las personas por cómo
se ven por cómo se visten por dónde
viven por qué idioma hablan por donde
trabajan
y el momento en que dejamos de hacer
estas etiquetas podemos darnos la
oportunidad de ver a la persona con la
que estamos hablando y a las personas
que nos rodean y aprendemos a amar las
porque nos amamos y respetamos sus vidas
porque respetamos la nuestra
y si se preguntan qué pasó con esa niña
que había crecido
pues
les cuento
que sin conocernos nos reconocemos
y un día esa niña encontró una caja
mientras buscaban cosas con su papá
encontró a aquella muñeca
es la muñeca a la que había dejado de
lado durante tantos años
lo que hice al ver la muñeca fue abrazar
a mi papá
lo abracé y le dije lo mucho que sentía
a las cosas que había dicho porque en
realidad no era consciente que al
rechazar a esta muñeca me rechazaba a mí
y también lo rechazaba él
mi papá me abrazo muy fuerte y me dijo
que el tema de identidad para él nunca
había sido importante y de hecho lo
evitaba porque no sabía cómo hablar de
esto
y que el momento en que yo empecé a
buscar construir mi identidad
y empezar a aceptarme él también empezó
a hacer este trabajo con él y llegó un
momento
en el qué
tanto mi papá como yo nos reconocimos
orgullosamente como afro bolivianos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]